many
silver and black fans were waiting for
the full schedule release raider tight
end darren waller busy raising awareness
and money for addiction treatment and
recovery for youth at risk john treach
caught up with a star at his annual
fundraiser
it is a banner day for hope and healing
in las vegas the second annual concert
to shine on featuring darren waller and
his foundation and i'm joined right now
by the raiders all pro tight end and
when you set out on this sober life
and wanted to make a difference did you
ever think you'd make this kind of
impact not even close
you know i was just trying to
present myself in a way that you know
somebody could maybe look to me and
learn something from my life but i never
thought it'd be on this grand of a scale
you know i thought just maybe like a
person to person thing i never thought i
would be have this level of platform to
be honest and you really were at a rock
bottom at one point it was only five
years ago and here you are living your
best life 16 touchdowns later
what message do you have for young
people
i would say one of my favorite quotes is
winston churchill
success is moving from failure to
failure without loss of enthusiasm
so it's like your journey doesn't have
to look perfect
no i've been arrested three times i've
been suspended at every level of
athletics i've ever played on
but somehow i'm still here you know
because i've decided to make a decision
to just you know do do right by myself
first and once i can do right by me i
can do right by other people as well and
just be a vessel of love and
good things will happen and the most
rewarding aspect of this entire journey
is what
seeing somebody's life be transformed
i mean it's cool to get up here and
perform some of my music and have a
bunch of family and stuff here but it's
really at the end of the day about
somebody's life being transformed you
know being a state of hopelessness like
i was just like not knowing
if there's going to be any more good or
any more reason to have hope but you
know to give that to somebody else
that's the biggest part
that's hope and someone who's looking
forward to the chargers in week one john
treach live local now